Mais ou menos 2 anos eu [música] venho
em efeito platô. Olá, meu nome é Jana,
tenho 39 anos. A minha barriga é muito
grande, isso me incomoda bastante.
Cabelo ralinho caindo, unhas quebrando,
tudo. Nunca posso ter uma unha grande e
pele muito ressecada nos braços, pernas,
calcanhares ficam rachados, né, pela
ressecamento. Então eu tive que tirar o
[música] útero ovário. Com isso, eu
entrei numa menopausa antes do tempo,
comecei a engordar, mas fora isso,
[música] a qualidade da minha saúde
também junto. Então, meus exames todos
desregulados, tireide desregulada, sono
desregulado, [música]
tudo. E com com o desafio dos s dias, eu
percebi que estava pior do que eu
imaginava. E o mais triste [música] é ir
médicos e eles me falarem: "Como você
não pode tomar hormônios, a gente não
tem nada para fazer por você. Você tem
que ser grata porque você está viva.
Você tá aqui com a sua família e com o
seu filho. Então assim, eu fui
sentenciada a viver do jeito que eu
estava vivendo. Comecei [música] a
engordar depois da minha gravidez há 25
anos atrás. E o meu os meus o meu peso
ideal ideal ideal seria 65 kg e eu
cheguei esse mês a 90 kg. Sempre tive
aquela de sanfona que falam, né,
[música] que emagrece, engorda,
emagrece, engorda. Eu não queria nem,
ah, cheguei ao ponto de pensar, a partir
de agora eu vou engordar 120 kg para
poder fazer bariátrica para voltar pro
meu peso, porque para mim era tinha que
ser tudo cirurgia, medicação. Comecei
acreditando que iria conseguir. [música]
>> Eu estou na obesidade nível dois. Nós
não acreditamos mais em nós. No meu
caso, era assim. tantas tentativas,
tantas dietas, eh atividade física e sem
o controle da alimentação, sem conhecer
o que eu posso e o que eu não posso
comer e quais são os melhores horários
para isso. Eh, descobrir [música] o que
é que tá atrapalhando o meu sono e
dentre outros sintomas. Bom dia.
[música] Meu nome é Adriana. Eu venho de
um processo de uma cirurgia que eu
engordei bastante [música]
e há muito tô sentindo unha fraca,
cabelo caindo, ficando bem [música]
careca, bem um cabelo bem falhado e
achando normal, menopausa, [música]
idade, normal. Aí percebi que a minha
tireoide [música]
estava me trazendo para esse lugar que
não me pertence, não me pertence mesmo.
Eu já tenho [música] 60 anos e quero
aposentar, viajar, aproveitar a vida.
Não quero ser uma velha de 60 anos,
gorda, com dores e tem anos no saído.
Fiquei extremamente feliz e empolgada
quando me pesei hoje pela manhã porque
eu perdi 4, kg.
>> Diminuí 4 kg. A minha barriga tá bem
menor. Tem sido muito prazeroso ver a
minha barriga desinchar, né? Eu diminuí
muito a barriga nesses dias de jejum. Em
menos de 7 dias eu eliminei 4 kg e estou
muito feliz, muito feliz. Deu assim uma
redução nas medidas, as roupas, né,
estão, a gente percebe nas roupas e eu
já estou muito feliz. Eu alcancei a meta
de 3,1.
Estou muito feliz. Já perdi 3 kg. muito
feliz com os resultados que [música] eu
que eu já alcancei até agora e pretendo
alcançar mais, [música] mais e mais,
porque eu quero me manter com corpo
bacana, com corpo saudável,
principalmente pela minha saúde, não
tanto por emagrecer, mas pela minha
saúde. Muito feliz, bem mais magra, bem
[música] mais sem barriga.
Olha a minha [música] feliz demais.
Muito feliz com esse resultado. Eu
agradeço imensamente
a você, Dr. Renan, doqui, pelo apoio.
Perdi 4,G 400 g. Eu não achava assim que
eu me senti que eu estava mais leve.
Isso foi muito bom.
>> Hoje fazem se dias que eu estou na
dieta. Eu consegui perder 4,G700 g. Eu
foram eliminados 6,6g, mas vai muito
além do peso.
>> Bom dia, bom dia, bom dia, bom dia,
meninas. Sejam muito bem-vindas à nossa
terceira aula do desafio do jejum. Vamos
com tudo, hein, gente. E vocês aqui, ó,
tava acompanhando os comentários de
vocês. Vocês, nossa, conhecimento
liberta, assim, o conhecimento liberta,
porque é como quando vocês veem mulheres
como vocês, né, que tinham tentado de
tudo, que queriam engordar para fazer
bariátrica. Muitos de vocês já passaram
por isso ou até já fizeram bariátrica. E
o que que acontece, né, que a gente hoje
a gente consegue ter uma visão bem
diferente de tudo que você já tentou
para emagrecer, é a visão do do
autoconhecimento.
Quando a gente fala sobre
autoconhecimento,
vem na nossa cabeça muito sobre a
mentalidade, você se conhecer, conhecer
seu comportamento, o seu padrão de
pensamento. O autoconhecimento. Muita
gente fala sobre você colocar os seus
limites, de você entender até onde as
pessoas podem chegar com você, o que é
bom para você, o que não é. Mas o
autoconhecimento que eu quero que vocês
tenham nessa semana é um
autoconhecimento diferente. É um
autoconhecimento sobre a sua fisiologia,
sobre os seus sintomas, sobre a sua
saúde, sobre os seus hormônios. você
conseguir olhar pro seu corpo com um
pouco mais de carinho, um pouco mais de
de de atenção e você descobrir que pera
aí, não é normal eu ter uma unha fraca,
não é normal meu metabolismo ser lento,
não é normal ter queda de cabelo, não é
normal viver no efeito sanfona, não é
normal ter barriga, porque não é
genética, não é idade e a gente já
descobriu isso. Portanto, meninas, sejam
muito bem-vindas. Portanto, sejam muito
bem-vindas à nossa
terceira aula do Desafio do jejum.
Então, olha, primeiro quero agradecer
vocês que foram lá no nosso post de
ontem, comentaram,
vocês criaram coragem, conseguem se
abrir ali com a gente, porque aquilo
conta pontinhos na hora da gente
escolher a campeã do nosso concurso,
viu, meninas? Então, olha, tem gente
aqui de tudo qualquer lugar, mas olha,
mais do que isso, vocês têm que fazer
parte de vocês. Portanto, esse esse
nosso desafio do jejum, como eu já falei
as duas nas duas últimas aulas, ele não
é sobre o jejum em si, ele é sobre você.
E como algumas de vocês falar falaram
aqui, ó, o conhecimento liberta.
O conhecimento liberta. E alguém falou:
"Já estou gostando dos resultados".
Mas mais do que resultados é
transformação de saúde, aprendizado e o
que que você vai fazer com todas essas
ferramentas. Portanto, sejam muito
bem-vindas porque a nossa aula três
acaba de começar e é uma aula melhor do
que a outra, viu, meninas? Então, o que
que te aguarda nessa nossa terceira
aula? Vamos falar sobre base hormonal
metabólica. Hoje a gente começa a
analisar e tratar os seus problemas
hormonais metabólicos. Sim, porque não
adianta, né? A gente já construiu a base
do conhecimento, vocês aprenderam sobre
a tríade, vocês aprenderam sobre qual
que é a tríade, mente, base hormonal
metabólica, mentalidade, base hormonal
metabólica e ciclagem de dietas. Vocês
aprenderam sobre todos os erros que
vocês cometem na tentativa de emagrecer.
E hoje a gente vai começar a analisar e
tratar os seus hormônios, porque vocês
preencheram mapa radar de problemas. Em
cima disso, agora a gente consegue
tratar cada um dos seus problemas.
Então, uma breve revisão do que
aconteceu na aula dois ontem. Você teve
acesso aos pilares do sucesso do
emagrecimento definitivo. Eu te
entreguei o radar de problemas.
Preencheram, gente, hein? Vocês
preencheram radar de problemas e vocês
descobriram quais os hormônios estão
alterados na sua base hormonal
metabólica? Então, lá na primeira aula,
eu te entreguei o mapa do emagrecimento
e você descobriu a relação da sua
pontuação com a sua saúde e em cima
disso o seu perfil hormonal. Qual o seu
perfil hormonal? Você é o perfil
hormonal sentinela, refém,
sobrecarregada, prisioneira. Qual desses
perfis é o seu? Porque quando você olha,
ah, meu exame tá tudo bem, tá tudo
normal. Mas quem diz que os exames falam
tudo que você precisa saber sobre você?
Os seus exames, eles vão falar o quê?
Eles vão falar quando o problema já se
instalou. Seus exames começam a alterar
quando você começa a entrar aqui, ó, na
refém e no perfil sobrecarregado. Aqui
os seus exames começam a alterar. Mas se
você tá no perfil sentinela, no seu
perfil sentinela, seus exames vão estar
normais, considerado normais, mas o seu
corpo já começou a dar sinais de alerta
de que alguma coisa não está caminhando
bem. E quando você tá no perfil refém,
você já está presa desse circuito
hormonal. Mas ainda não tem muitos
sintomas. Você parece que as coisas
estão normais para você. Quando você tá
no perfil sobrecarregada, que a
pontuação maior do que 20, aí você já
tem comprometimento. E quando você tá no
com a pontuação acima de 40, daí você se
tornou a prisioneira desse circuito
hormonal. E hoje a gente começa a tirar
essas amarras, a gente começa a a te dar
a chave desses cadeados, desse circuito
hormonal pra gente começar a tratar cada
um desses pontos.
>> [roncando]
>> Então, liberei para vocês nossa segunda
aula, revelei ontem, te entreguei o
radar de problemas e revelei a relação
de cada um dos problemas hormonais do
seu mapa. O problema um, cortisol,
problema dois, insulina. Problema três,
tireoide. Problema quatro, sono.
Problema cinco, intestino. E aí, qual
que foi a sua maior pontuação?
Em qual setor que foi a sua maior
pontuação? Ou foi tudo ou foi monte?
[suspirando] Ou foi monte? Ei, meninas,
mas eu quero agradecer todas vocês pelas
milhares de visualizações da nossa aula
dois. Isso mostra comprometimento
de vocês
e também por todos os milhares de
comentários do nosso post do #eu meolho,
porque agora você consegue se olhar de
uma forma diferente. Eu tô vendo aqui
vocês colocando maior pontuação foi
tireoide, foi cortisol, foi intestino,
vários foi o monte. [risadas] É isso,
gente. Mas saber que sua saúde tava
ruim, você já sabia. Mas eu quero
agradecer todo o comprometimento de
vocês. E aí vocês foram lá para mim,
contaram, né, tudo que tava acontecendo.
Olha só o que a Suzi falou. Agora eu me
enxergo porque há muito tempo eu não
entendi os sinais que meu corpo mandava.
E é isso. Você consegue agora
identificar os seus sintomas. Olha só o
que que a Idol falou. [roncando] Olha,
eu vejo agora que eu sou muito amada,
cuidado por Deus e eu acredito muito em
sinais de Deus e tudo fez muito sentido
para mim. Quando você falou que a culpa
não é minha por eu estar assim, porque
eu tenho intestino que não funciona
desde adolescente, tem problemas
hormonais, alteração de pâncreas,
tireoide, metabolismo e sempre fui a
gordinha da casa pulando de dieta em
dieta no efeito sanfone definitivo.
[roncando] É libertador, né? É
libertador quando você consegue enxergar
que a culpa não é sua. Olha só o que que
a Suzi falou.
Agora eu enxergo que meus hormônios
estavam desregulados, por isso não
importava quanto meu esforço fizesse, o
peso não mudava. Vocês fazem muito
esforço? É assim, gente, foram milhares
de comentários de vocês, milhares de
comentários. E eu quero agradecer cada
uma de vocês que tiveram coragem de ir
lá comentar, porque isso aqui conta
pontinhos, viu? No final da semana pro
concurso que tá acontecendo. E quais as
dúvidas, quais as dúvidas vocês podem
apresentar aqui hoje nesse nosso jejum?
Porque hoje vocês estão no nosso segundo
dia de 16 horas. Bateremos 16 horas
hoje.
Aí mesmo assim muitas dúvidas surgem:
"Ah, mas eu [limpando a garganta] posso
água de coco? Não pode no jejum, vai
quebrar jejum. Posso misturar diferentes
fontes de proteína? Se você quiser, você
pode. Você pode pegar um pedaço da
porção de frango, um pedaço da porção de
carne de boi. Pode misturar sem nenhum
problema. Posso tomar o leite de vaca?
Gente, o leite, a gente falou ontem, eu
gostaria que o leite e o líquido essa
semana pelo menos você não tomasse,
porque uma das coisas que eu preciso
fazer com vocês é controle de insulina.
E o leite ele vai ter uma absorção mais
rápida e a insulina sobe. Ah, mas eu
posso colocar gordura no café? Eu vi um
profissional falando que se você colocar
óleo de coco no café, não vai quebrar o
jejum. Depende do tipo de jejum. Se for
um jejum mais prolongado de 20 horas até
OK, mas 16 não. Nesse nosso jejum de 18
horas que vocês farão amanhã também não,
viu gente? O jejum de 18 horas que vocês
faram também não. Não pode colocar óleo
de coco no café, não pode colocar
gordura porque senão isso vai quebrar o
jejum calórico. Nós estamos aqui fazendo
um jejum calórico esses dias. lá no
jejum de 20 horas, 18 para 20 horas, a
gente entra num processo de jejum
metabólico que aí sim até pode consumir,
mas eu vou explicar para vocês na no
final da semana. Então, hoje vocês
entram no segundo dia de 16 horas de
jejum. O que que começa a acontecer no
seu corpo?
Insulina cai. Então, presta atenção
nisso daqui. O que que começa a
acontecer no seu corpo?
Cai a insulina. O seu corpo prepara o
ambiente para queima de gordura.
começa a acontecer um processo de
turnover celular, mas acontece de uma
forma muito sutil. O seu corpo começa a
trocar células velhas por células novas
e de repente uma potencialização de
mobilização de gordura corporal como
fonte de energia. Então, a partir de
agora, do segundo dia do jejum de 16
horas, o seu corpo começa a utilizar
gordura como fonte de energia. Então
você começa a queimar a gordura e aí
glicose começa a estabilizar, níveis de
insulina estabilizam e vocês começam a
ter mais energia, mais disposição
e a dor de cabeça vai embora, o
mal-estar vai embora, você desincha,
melhora a função de fígado, melhorou
função de fígado, melhora a conversão de
hormônios do quê? Hormônios da sua
tireoide.
Mas eu quero que vocês tenham muita
atenção, porque amanhã vocês farão 18
horas de jejum. Vocês já estão
familiarizadas com todos os materiais,
com toda a nossa plataforma, com tudo
que tem lá dentro. Qual o meu horário
preferido de fazer um jejum de 18 horas?
Eu, isso é meu, você pode adaptar do
jeito que você quiser. Eu, Dr. Renan, eu
prefiro nunca mudar muito o meu horário
do almoço. Eu sempre almoço por volta de
1 da tarde, então não mudo muito meu
horário de almoço. Então, eu prefiro
fazer a última refeição do dia anterior
mais cedo. Portanto, o meu horário
preferido para fazer um jejum de 18
horas, é, eu faço ali minha última
refeição do dia por volta de 6 da tarde
e aí eu vou almoçar no meu horário no
dia seguinte.
Daí dá 18 horas, mas lá dentro da nosso
do cronograma tem os horários. Dia que é
jejum de 18 horas, o seu horário da
última refeição e a opção do horário da
primeira refeição do dia. Entendido?
Então você pode fazer do jeito que você
quiser, mas você tem que chegar nas 18
horas. Então eu não gosto de fazer assim
quando eu jejumo 18 horas, fazer minha
última refeição 8 da noite, 9 da noite,
porque lá no outro dia eu vou ter que
almoçar duas, 3 da tarde e eu não gosto
disso. Então eu sempre puxo minha última
refeição do dia do dia anterior um
pouquinho mais cedo, mas é uma opção
sua. Se você tiver fome, o que que você
pode fazer no período de jejum? Você
pode colocar psílium. Quem tiver fome no
período de jejum, você pode colocar
psílium.
Psílium, que ela fibra, ela não vai
quebrar o seu jejum. E quando você
consome uma colher de sopa de psílium
com copo de água, vai virar uma gelatina
no seu estômago e vai te dar uma
sensação de saciedade.
Então você pode colocar fibra se você
quiser, não é obrigatório. Tem uma outra
fibra que é o glucomanano.
Presta atenção aqui. Tem uma outra fibra
que é o glucomanano. O glucomananoano,
ele é cinco vezes mais potente que o
psílium para controlar aptite. Aí você
vai tomar uma colher de chá cheia de
glucoma nano com copo de água.
E gordura pode nesse período de jejum,
óleo de coco, azeite, não pode. Só vai
poder essa gordurinha se você quiser no
jejum de 20 horas, mas aqui 18 horas
ainda não.
Então tema da nossa aula de hoje, mas
antes, olha só, outras dúvidas aqui, né,
gente? Quando a gente fala sobre sobre
perda de peso,
quando a gente fala sobre perda de peso,
existem algumas coisas que a gente
precisa ter consciência, sabe?
Porque eu tenho, eu sei que tem muitas
alunas aqui que tem problema de
tireoide. Quem é que tem problema
tireoide? Quem é que teve pontuação alta
na tireoide? Quem é que toma remédio
tireoide? Então, se você tem problema de
tireoide,
por que que esse jejum vai ajudar
inclusive quem tem problema de tireoide?
Porque um dos problemas da tireoide é o
seu fígado. Gente, grava isso que eu vou
falar. Se você vive cansado, inha fraca,
metabolismo lento, preguiça, desânimo,
talvez é sua tireoide que tá lenta. Só
que a tireoide ela produz o hormônio que
é o T4.
Só que esse T4 ele precisa virar o T3
para você ter energia, para você ter
disposição. E onde que vira o T3? no seu
fígado. Portanto, uma pessoa que tem um
fígado doente, você que já tem gordura
no fígado, você que tem barriga, você
que acorda mais de duas vezes à noite
para urinar, você tem um fígado
sobrecarregado. Então, a conversão dos
seus hormônios da tireoide não acontece
direito. Então, você pode até ter uma
tireoide perfeita nos exames, porque o
exame de TSH, uma tireoide perfeita, tem
que tá abaixo de 2,2.
Se o seu TSH tiver de 2.3 para cima,
tireoide tá tá lenta. Mas se seu TSH
tiver ótimo, mas você tem um fígado
alterado, você vai ter todos os sintomas
estereoide e esse estratégia de jejum
vai melhorar essa função de fígado e
consequentemente essa conversão dos
hormônios da tireoide.
Então, sobre fígado, né, quem aqui tem
problema de fígado, uma coisa muito
legal que pode ser utilizada é o chá de
espinheira santa com cardomariano.
Toma de manhã, de noite, uns dois meses,
ajuda a tratar seu fígado, mas é muito
importante que você faça o tratamento do
fígado, porque o fígado não é só para
tireoide, para você desinchar, pra
resistência insulínica, para cortisol. O
fígado, ele é o grande catalisador de
tudo no nosso corpo. Ele é como se fosse
um relógio do seu corpo. Eu preciso de
um fígado saudável para que seu sistema
renal funcione, para que coração
funcione, sistema digestivo funcione,
para que você elimine toxinas.
E essa estratégia jum começa também a
tratar o seu fígado. Claro que você vai
precisar de continuidade desse
tratamento, porque não existe cura em 7
dias. Cura em 7 dias, não. É o início
desse reset metabólico. A mesma coisa
tireoide. Não existe cura. Você que já
toma remédio tireoide, você vai precisar
aprender o que eu vou falar hoje sobre
tireoide para vocês, para essa
continuidade. E um grande medo é: "Dr
Renan, mas eu perco peso e recupero
tudo."
Essa sua dúvida, ela vai ser quebrada
hoje porque a gente vai falar sobre base
hormonal metabólica.
E o grande medo, né? Menopausa, porque
depois da menopausa parece que tudo
mudou, parece que tudo ficou lento.
Menopausa é só desculpa. Idade é só
desculpa.
O problema é que
quando você busca um médico para tentar
emagrecer e ele não te fala sobre
problemas hormonais, sobre cortisol,
sobre sono, sobre intestino, sobre
tireoide, sobre insulina,
você começa a achar que tudo é por conta
da sua idade, tudo é por conta da
menopausa, mas isso é só uma desculpa.
independente de menopausa, independente
de idade, você perde peso como qualquer
pessoa. E é sério isso que eu tô
falando.
Então você começa a criar uma barriga na
menopausa que você não tinha antes.
Criou barriga, você sabe que isso tá
ligado à resistência insulínica e
cortisol. E se você dorme mal, porque
depois a menopausa do sono piora, devido
à queda de melatonina, que é o hormônio
natural do sono. Então você começa a ter
um tanto de problema e você coloca o
peso todo sobre a menopausa e sua idade.
Mas entenda uma coisa,
isso não é uma verdade. E hoje a gente
vai começar a tratar, identificar cada
um, cada um desses problemas. Então, o
tema da nossa aula de hoje é base
hormonal metabólica. Mas eu vou te
explicar principalmente sobre
principalmente sobre
o circuito hormonal da obesidade.
O circuito hormonal da obesidade.
Quem tá presa nesse circuito hormonal da
obesidade, dificilmente
dificilmente consegue manter o peso
porque você tá refém de um sistema que
você não domina. Então, olha só isso
daqui. [limpando a garganta]
O grande problema hoje de redes sociais
é a burrice ideológica da maioria dos
dos nutres que falam que a única coisa
que importa é caloria. E daí você vê um
monte de profissional: "Ah, você pode
trocar isso por isso porque tem a mesma
caloria. Troca isso por isso porque tem
a mesma caloria". Ao invés de comer uma
alimentação saudável, você pode comer
seu bombom, seu chocolate, um pedaço de
pão que tem a mesma quantidade de
caloria.
Só que,
só que
gente,
se você tem resistência insulínica, esse
açúcar e esse pão aumentam sua insulina.
você engorda também pro mecanismo
hormonal e você começa a carregar um
monte de peso hormonal que você não sabe
qual a causa. Então, quero que vocês
prestem muita atenção nisso daqui. A
mochila
da dúvida de vocês, a mochila da vida de
vocês. Vocês carregam ansiedade, peso,
expectativas. Aí vocês passam a ter
dores no corpo, frustrações, ansiedade,
fadiga, cansaço, preguiça, desânimo. E
de repente você vê que tá com barriga,
baixa autoestima, não se sente bonita e
vem o excesso de peso.
Então, a mochila da sua vida, ela tá
muito pesada e você quer carregar o peso
por você e pelos outros.
Você quer cuidar dos seus pais, da sua
casa, do marido, dos filhos. Você quer
cuidar da vida de todo mundo, mas e
você? Você só carrega esse peso?
Você só carrega esse peso. Então, esse
peso que vocês carregam, a gente precisa
começar a escolher o que que a gente vai
tirar dessa mochila, senão a vida fica
muito pesada.
Você sente que tá tudo muito pesado,
você sente que tá tudo mais difícil,
só que você não precisa carregar tudo
isso para sempre. Aí você tem a
preocupação com a sua família, com o seu
futuro, com a sua própria vida, com o
seu espelho, com as suas roupas,
com a falta de tempo. Aí tem intestino
preso, aí tem um sono que não é bom, tem
um efeito sanfona que não te deixa e
fica muito pesado isso. Por que que sua
vida fica pesado? Por causa dessa
ansiedade de não dar conta de nada. Você
parece que você não consegue fazer nada
bem feito.
E aí você começa a colocar na sua
mochila da vida isso daqui.
Aí eu quero te perguntar, você acha que
você é uma pessoa cansada, sem energia?
Barriga te incomoda? Vive no efeito
sanfona,
unhas e cabelos fracos?
Você vive irritada, sem paciência? Vive
inchada, tem inchaço, retenção de
líquido? Você sente deprimida para
baixo? tem oscilação de humor, cada dia
tá de um jeito.
E o metabolismo, você acha que a culpa é
o seu metabolismo lento?
E o sono? Seu sono é ruim, de má
qualidade?
E o efeito sanfona? Vai e volta, vai
volta, vai e volta, vai e volta. E as
manchas no corpo? Tem manchas
escurecidas? Taxila, virilha, pescoço
mais escurecido,
estress, ansiedade, bib estressada,
ansiosa.
Quem aqui já retirou vesícula? Hum.
[roncando] Quem aqui já retirou
vesícula?
Se você retirou vesícula, você passa ter
deficiência de vitaminas A, D, E, K,
todo complexo B.
Intestino preso. Tem intestino preso ou
solto demais?
fibromialgia, dorpo. Tem gente com
fibromialgia aqui. Aí você passa tomar
antidepressivo, anciolíticos que te
engordam e a deficiência de algumas
vitaminas é a causa disso aqui. E
síndrome de ovário policístico. Falamos
ontem da história da Diana. Síndrome de
ovário policístico a causa resistência
insulínica.
Glicose alterada, colesterol alto,
tireoide. Quem é que tem o
hipotiroidismo?
ou se o TSH tá acima de 2.3, de 2.3 para
cima.
E esses sintomas aqui, quem tem esses
sintomas? Mãos e pés frios, unha fraca,
oscilação de humor, a pele às vezes
parece estar descamando um pouquinho,
mas ressecada, barriga, queda de cabelo,
um desânimo, sono não é reparador.
E esses sintomas, manchas escurecidas,
axila, virilha escurecida,
acne mesmo você que já passou na
adolescência há muito tempo ainda tem
acne, aquelas verruguinhas no pescoço.
E eu te digo uma coisa, se você tem
apenas um desses sintomas, escuta o que
eu tô falando, se você tem um desses
sintomas aqui, a sua base hormonal
metabólica está desregulada.
Um desses sintomas, e eu te digo, o que
que o profissional, médico ou nutrire
que você foi,
te falou sobre isso?
Nada. quer te passar um remédio, quer te
passar uma canetinha, ele quer te passar
uma dieta que às vezes a dieta é boa. A
dieta às vezes você vai num
profissional, num nutre sério, ele
calcula uma dieta para você, mas esse
cálculo de dieta é considerado apenas
seu peso, percentual de gordura, sua
altura, massa magra e faz um cálculo,
mas não considerou os problemas
hormonais. E se você tem um desses
problemas,
sua base hormonal metabólica está
totalmente desregulada.
E eu quero te fazer uma pergunta assim
muito séria.
Será de verdade que é falta de força de
vontade?
Porque a vida inteira você achou, para
tudo agora, eu quero que você me escute
com muita atenção, porque a vida inteira
você achou que seu sobrepeso era por
falta de força de vontade. E já falaram
isso para você: "Ah, mas você não tem
força de vontade o suficiente para
manter sua dieta".
Então, quero que você
presta muita atenção no que eu vou falar
agora. Sabe por quê?
Porque a sua vida inteira você foi
julgada por não conseguir e você se
julgou. O pior juiz da sua vida foi você
mesma,
porque é você que tinha que se encarar
todo dia no espelho. Mas eu quero te
contar uma coisa que eu vejo todos os
dias nas minhas alunas.
Imagina uma coisa comigo aqui. Imagina
quem é que tem filho. Se você não tem
filho, provavelmente com certeza você
tem alguma criança na sua família.
Imagina uma criança, você vai lá buscar
o seu filho na escola. Você vai lá
buscar o seu filho na escola
e o seu filho é pequenininho, tá com
aquela mochila gigante,
cheia de coisa, com lancheira, com um
monte de apostila, com um monte de
caderno, com lápis de colorir. Aquela
mochila gigante. Tem 10 cadernos, um
para cada para cada matéria. E ele vem
capengando aquela mochila pesada. Tanto
é que até a orientação da escola é
cuidado por causa da coluna das crianças
e vem aquela criança carregando aquela
mochila pesada.
Ninguém olha pra criança, ninguém olha
para essa criança e fala assim: "Nossa,
meu Deus, como essa criança ela é
preguiçosa. É uma criança sem falta de
força de vontade porque ela não consegue
andar mais rápido por causa da mochila".
Você não olha, você olha pra criança e
fala assim: "Meu Deus, coitado dessa
criança. Vamos, vamos, vamos melhorar
essa mochila. Vamos, vamos fazer alguma
coisa. Vamos comprar uma mochila de de
carrinho.
Porque por que que ninguém olha pra
criança e fala: "Nossa, que criança sem
força de vontade de carregar essa
mochila".
Só que com você é diferente,
porque ninguém enxerga o que que você
carrega,
ninguém enxerga o quanto você se
esforça.
Eu te pergunto, o que que tem aí na sua
mochila?
Ninguém viu o que tem dentro da sua
mochila. Nem você olha para parar o que
que tem para ver o que que tem dentro da
sua mochila. Você carrega sua família
inteira, você cuida dos seus pais
idosos, você cuida de filho, você cuida
de casa, você tem o seu trabalho, você
tem as suas preocupações, tem brigas na
família e você carrega tudo sozinha.
Você tem que arrumar a casa, você tem
que cuidar de tudo. Seu trabalho que te
suga, que te pesa e ninguém pergunta
para você: "Nossa, tá pesado, né? Deixa
eu ver aí que que eu posso te ajudar".
Não, a única coisa que falam para você é
assim:
"Você tá com falta de força de vontade,
isso é muito injusto."
Só que você carrega tudo isso sem
reclamar. Você reclama para você, só que
aí responde no seu corpo,
numa fibromialgia, numa depressão, numa
ansiedade,
numa baixa autoestima. E não tem força
de vontade que resista isso não, viu,
gente?
Então, quero te perguntar, o que que
você tá carregando nessa mochila que tá
pesado?
Então, não é que você foi fraca, não é
que teve falta de força de vontade, é
porque você tinha esse tanto de problema
hormonal. Eu vi aqui, ó, vocês falam:
"Nossa, tem quase tudo isso".
E você vai colocando isso nessa sua
mochila da sua vida
e você ainda acha que a culpa é sua.
Você faz tudo certo, você faz dieta,
você come pouco, você toma o remédio que
te passa, você faz a cirurgia que te
indicam, você tenta fazer academia, você
tenta fazer caminhada, você tenta fazer
zumba, você tenta fazer um monte de
coisa,
só que o seu corpo vive em alerta.
Se você tem alteração de cortisol, que é
hormônio de estresse, vai viver em
alerta. Se você tem uma tiragade lenta,
vai viver em alerta. Se você tem, se
você tem resistência insulínica, é
alerta. Então, quero te falar uma coisa
assim, não é que seu corpo te sabota, é
um mecanismo de proteção. Os seus
hormônios alteram para um mecanismo de
proteção.
Seu corpo quer te proteger, ele quer te
manter viva e ele vai segurando as
pontas onde ele consegue.
Então, grave isso que eu vou te falar
agora. Seu corpo, ele não tá contra
você, não é? não é genética, não é nada
disso,
mas ele te dá sinais para você entender
onde você precisa cuidar.
Então eu quero aqui nessa aula de hoje,
eu não quero te passar mais uma dieta,
não quero te passar mais uma diquinha,
eu quero que você tire essa culpa,
porque a gente vai entender a causa
hormonal por trás de tudo isso que tá
acontecendo com você, porque nem tudo é
emocional.
na maioria das vezes é hormonal e o seu
emocional é uma resposta a essa mochila
que tá cheia demais de coisa que você
não consegue carregar. Então hoje eu
quero que vocês assumam um compromisso
de pelo menos olhar paraa sua vida e
vera aí o que que eu consigo tirar dessa
desse peso dessa mochila, desse peso da
minha vida. Então olha pra sua vida e
entenda assim: o que que eu consigo
tirar? O que que me causa ansiedade que
eu consigo tirar? O que que afeta meu
sono que eu consigo regular? Para onde
que eu preciso olhar aqui?
Porque é isso aqui que eu quero que
aconteça com vocês,
resolver o problema.
E o problema de da grande maioria aqui
não é emocional, tá longe de ser
emocional. Então quero que a mochila da
vida de vocês seja mais leve, com mais
autoestima, com mais energia. Você
voltar a ter planos, ter sonhos, ter
projetos na vida, cuidado com o corpo,
uma alimentação legal, saudável, um sono
de qualidade, uma autoestima lá em cima.
Porque aí
você para de reclamar. E assim como
algumas aqui que às vezes eu ver no chat
reclamando,
você que reclama,
isso isso não é você. Isso é uma
resposta a essa mochila pesada,
entende?
Então eu quero vocês com a mentalidade
de tirar peso dessa mochila e que esse
peso não é só emocional,
porque hoje vocês vão receber na nossa
terceira chave secreta, ao final dessa
aula, cada uma das aulas eu libero
chaves secretas, um e-book de tratamento
de base hormonal metabólica
para tratar o seu metabolismo. E hoje a
gente tem também a nossa terceiro,
terceiro bônus, viu, do nosso protocolo
acelera metabolismo. só ganha quem tá ao
vivo na aula que eu libero no final para
vocês. Então vamos hoje começar a não
falar sobre emocional, sobre
mentalidade. Eu quero tirar o peso da
mochila de vocês em cima disso aqui, ó,
da sua fisiologia, dos seus hormônios.
Então o tema de hoje, base hormonal
metabólica, porque vocês já descobriram
problemas da base hormonal metabólica
com radar de problemas de vocês. Então
quais os principais hormônios da base
hormonal metabólica? insulina,
intestino, tireoide, cortisoló, só
existem outros, mas esses aqui são os
principais.
E se você tem comprometimento em um
deles, você não perde peso, você vive no
efeito sanfona e pode gerar um efeito
dominó de afetar outros hormônios.
Entenda uma coisa, nada tá separado, mas
hoje eu preciso de falar sobre a tríade
hormonal da obesidade, o circuito
hormonal da obesidade que engloba
insulina, tireoide e cortisol. Então,
hoje a nossa aula vai ser focada em
tratar insulina, tireoide, cortisol.
Amanhã eu vou falar tudo sobre
intestino, tudo sobre sono e também vou
falar tudo sobre todas as dietas e
ciclagens de dietas. Então, o nosso foco
aqui hoje é insulina tireide cortisol.
Por quê? Por causa disso aqui,
tireoide, insulina, cortisol, eles fazem
parte de um circuito hormonal da
obesidade. E esse circuito hormonal da
obesidade, ele é interconectado. Se você
tem uma tireoide alterada, o cortisol
vai alterar e a insulina vai alterar. Se
você tem resistência insulínica, sua
tireoide fica lenta e o cortisol altera.
Se você tem estress cortisol alterado, a
tireoide fica sobrecarregada e seu corpo
passa a produzir mais insulina. Nada no
nosso corpo é separado. Isso aqui faz
parte de bases da medicina chinesa que
tem todo componente de conexão
energética. Por exemplo, se você tem um
fígado alterado, altera seu sistema
renal, seu sistema cardiovascular
e intestino. Se você tem, se você tem
um, o rim sobrecarregado,
você altera adrenal, cortisol e altera
seu sistema cardiovascular. Então, no
nosso corpo, tudo tem uma dependência
energética, nada tá sozinho. Por isso
que muitas de vocês aqui tem o exame
normal, só que você tem os sintomas de
outros problemas hormonais, mas tem uma
causa raiz.
Só que você que tá ali no na no perfil
sobrecarregada ou
ou prisioneira, você provavelmente já
tem comprometimento de mais componentes
hormonais do que um só, do que uma raiz.
Quais são os hormônios? Então, vamos
entender isso daqui. Tireoide. A
tireoide ela produz o T4, só que a
formativa do hormão da tireoide é o T3.
E esse T4 ele vira o T3 no fígado.
Quem produz insulina, pâncreas. Quem
produz cortisol, adrenal. Então são
esses três órgãos, pâncreas, adrenal,
tireoide. Eles são conectados
energeticamente e se você tem alteração
em um deles, você está presa nesse
circuito hormonal da obesidade. Quem tá
presa nesse circuito hormonal da
obesidade pode ter um metabolismo 50%
mais lento. Por isso que você faz uma
dieta e come pouco e o peso não cai. Eu
preciso começar a tratar isso em você.
Esses aqui são sintomas de estereoide.
Prestem atenção. Esses aqui são sintomas
de cheiro
quem aqui tem esses sintomas?
Quem aqui tem esses sintomas?
Fadiga, preguiça, desânimo, mãos e pés
frios, oscilação de humor, unha fraca,
queda de cabelo, barriga, não perde
peso, mesmo comendo pouco.
Sintomas intestino preso também, quem
tem problema em tireoide,
se você tem essas, você tem tireide
alterada. E se o seu exame de TSH está
de 2.3 para cima, você vai ter todos
esses sintomas. Se você toma purã, levo
cintroide, tiroóxid, leva tiroxina, que
é o remédio de tireoide, você vai ter
todos esses sintomas porque você não
está repondo o T3. Você precisa repor o
T3. E como que repõe o T3? Ele é
calculado em cima do seu remédio
tiereoide da e do quanto o seu TSH tá
alterado. Como que você vai descobrir se
sua tireoide tá alterada? Eu quero que
todos vocês façam esse teste aqui. Tira
print dessa tela para vocês não
esquecerem. Tira print da tela. Tira
print. Gente, vocês vão fazer o teste do
termômetro para tireoide. Vocês vão
pegar o termômetro, deixar do lado da
sua cama.
Sem se levantar da cama, você vai medir
sua temperatura por três dias seguidos.
Vai lá, mede sua temperatura por três
dias seguidos.
Se por três dias seguidos a sua
temperatura ficar abaixo de 36.4,
é a sua tiroide que tá desregulada.
grava isso. Se por três dias seguidos a
sua temperatura tiver abaixo de 36.4,
a sua tireoide está desregulada. Porque
uma das funções da tireoide é controlar
a temperatura corporal noturna. E foi
exatamente isso que a gente fez com a
Raimunda. Gente, a Raimunda era igual a
vocês, metabolismo lento, não perde
peso, barriga.
E quando a gente tratou a tireoide dela,
identificamos essa deficiência
e a gente fez a reposição, no caso dela
pô de T4, reposição do T3, ela não
perdia 1 kg com dieta cortando
carboidrato. Ela fazia duas refeições um
dia só.
Ela perdeu 8 kg em 45 dias, ao todo 16.6
kg em 3 meses, de forma natural,
tratando base hormonal metabólica, como
aluna PEF 360.
Agora [roncando] eu quero que vocês
olhem isso daqui. Quem aqui tem esses
sintomas? Axila escurecida, viril
escurecida, acne nessa região do queixo,
peito cós, aumento de pelo no corpo,
pelos mais grossos,
aquelas verruguinhas aumentadas no
pescoço, rosto, pele mais oleosa. Se
você tem esses sintomas, mais vontade de
carboidrato, não consegue ficar muito
tempo sem se alimentar,
você tem resistência à insulina.
O que que é resistência à insulina?
Presta atenção que isso aqui é um
problema de mais de 80% de vocês.
O que que é? Coloca aqui quem tem. Tem
gente fala: "Ó, tenho todos, tem todos
os sintomas.
Se você tem barriga, você tem
resistência insulina. Se você vive no
efeito sanfona, você tem resistência
insulínica. Cada vez que você sofre com
efeito sanfona acima de 5 kg, o seu
corpo fica mais resistente à insulina. E
eu preciso tratar isso. Vamos entender
aqui que que é que que é resistência
insulínica. Insulina é o hormônio que a
gente produz. Então, quando você come um
pão, o pão sobe isso aqui de glicose no
sangue e seu corpo produz isso de
insulina para dar conta do açúcar que
esse pongerou no seu sangue. Então, a
insulina faz o quê? Abaixa a glicose.
Por que que o diabético aplica insulina?
O diabético aplica insulina para quê?
para baixar a glicose, porque o corpo do
diabético não produz mais insulina.
Então, quando você era mais magra,
quantos anos atrás você era mais magra?
Uns 10, uns c uns 2, 5, 10 anos atrás.
Imagina você lá com seus 20 anos mais
magra, você comia um pão,
você, seu corpo produzia, subia isso
aqui de glicose do seu corpo e aí você
produzia isso de insulina para baixar a
glicose. Pronto. Isso era como seu corpo
funcionava quando você era saudável. Só
que com o passar dos anos você vem
ganhando peso, efeito sanfona, comendo
errado. O que que acontece?
Hoje você comeu um pão, continua subindo
isso aqui de glicose. Só que o seu corpo
precisa produzir duas, 3, [roncando]
4, cinco, seis vezes mais insulina do
que precisa para dar conta desse pão.
Então, o seu pico de insulina, ele é
muito maior do que precisa.
E quanto mais sobe insulina, mais
estimula gordura corporal. Por isso que
você engorda rápido hoje em dia, porque
sua insulina sobe muito. Então isso é
resistência à insulina, produzir mais
insulina do que precisa. Mais de 80%
aqui produz mais insulina do que
precisa.
Só que resistência insulínica não é só
fazer dieta, não é só cortar cortar
carboidrato. Você precisa entender isso
daqui para você ver como só fazer dieta
não tem resultado. Você precisa de
tratamento.
Quando você tem barriga, essa gordura
visceral que você tem, aquela gordura
interna que tá lá entranhada nos órgãos,
ela produz uma substância inflamatória
que se chama citocina inflamatória.
Então eu preciso e essa barriga tá tá
diretamente ligada à sua insulina. Então
eu preciso combater inflamação, entrar
com antioxidante, seja utilizando
cúrcuma, algum antioxidante como
resveratrol, como vitamina C, como eh
própolis, enfim, existem vários
antioxidantes naturais e alguns que você
pode manipular ou comprar em farmácia
como vitaminas. Só que você tá presa
nesse ciclo. Você tem barriga, aumenta
inflamação, pior insulina, mais
inflamação, você come mais, ganha peso,
mais inflamação, mais insulina. E você
fica nesse ciclo que você não sabe onde
começou o quê. Se você tem deficiência
de cromo, magnésio, zinco, vitamina D,
você cria resistência insulínica de uma
forma mais fácil, de uma forma mais
facilitada. Olha só o caso da Suzane. A
Susane tinha principalmente resistência
insulínica. Você que é pré-diabética,
primeiro você fica, grava isso que eu
vou te falar agora. Qual que é o perigo
da resistência insulina? Você cria
resistência insulínica, ela é a primeira
etapa para você ficar diabética.
Primeiro resistência sulínica, depois
pré-diabete, depois diabetes. Então quem
tem resistência, quem tem pré-diabete
aqui, seu grau de resistência ulínica é
muito mais elevado. E a gente tratou. E
aí, nesse ciclo de inflamação,
a Suzane criou fibromialgia, dor no
corpo,
vesícula, teve que retirar e passa a ter
deficiência de vitaminas. E a gente fez
reposição das vitaminas da vesícula.
Essas vitaminas ajudam a tirar as dores
da fibromialgia. Ela era pré-diabética,
a gente tratou e ela perdeu quase 13 kg
em 45 dias ao todo 22 kg, gente, de
forma natural
e rápido, porque é o seu corpo
trabalhando para você. [roncando] Só que
tem muita gente aqui estressada. Quem é
que é estressada, ansiosa? Você que é
estressada, ansiosa.
Cortisol. O cortisol é hormônio do
stress. E ele é muito importante para
você ter energia, para você ter
vitalidade.
Só que o cortisol, [limpando a garganta]
eu quero explicar uma coisa aqui que é
muito importante. O cortisol ele tem que
est no meio termo. Se ele fica muito
alto, você fica estressada com muita
energia elétrica. Quem é que se sente
estressada elétrica com energia?
Cortisol alto. Quem é que se sente
estressada, cansada? cortisol baixo.
Então, se você sente estressada,
cansada,
quem que sente estressada cansada ou
estressada elétrica?
Tem gente falou aqui, ó, [risadas] nasci
estressada.
Então, se você é uma pessoa estressada,
cansada, cortisol baixo. Estressada
elétrica, cortisol alto. Os dois
engordam, os dois diminuem seu
metabolismo.
Os dois engordam, os dois diminuem. o
seu metabolismo, grava isso. E aí o
cortisol é um problema, porque você
engorda sempre precisar comer. Já viu
isso? Tem gente que fala: "Nossa,
engordo só de respirar". Provavelmente
cortisol alterado. Por quê? A sua
barriga, a gordura da barriga tem
receptores para cortisol. Se você é uma
pessoa com alteração de cortisol, você
ganha barriga com mais facilidade.
Por isso que você come pouco e o peso
não cai.
Então, olha o que que acontece. Quem tem
alteração de cortisol, estresse fica
elevado, aumenta cortisol e aí o
cortisol sabe o que que ele faz? Acumula
gordura na barriga. Depois a gente vem
aqui pro três, ó. Gordura abdominal faz
o quê? Citocina inflamatória. Aumenta o
quê? Insulina.
E aí você engorda para um mecanismo
hormonal,
não por comer errado.
E eu quero te perguntar uma coisa.
Você acha que você tem controle sobre
isso?
Quando eu falo, gente, não é papo.
Quando eu falo a culpa não é sua pelo
peso que você tá, é porque não é mesmo.
Você tá preso em um circuito hormonal
que você não tem controle. Isso aqui não
é falta de força de vontade. Isso aqui
não é emocional. Isso aqui não é
fraqueza da sua parte. Isso aqui te
controla.
Não tem força de vontade que vença isso
daqui.
E foi isso que aconteceu com a Pâmela,
gente. A Pâela, ela mudou de cidade,
teve filho e por causa de estress,
alteração de cortisol, ela engordou.
E aí no PEF
falei: "Pâila, a gente precisa cuidar de
resistência insulínica e cortisol que
você tem de alteração?" Ela falou: "Tor,
mas só isso?"
Falei, não é só isso, isso já é muito.
Acho que eu travei.
Eu travei aí, Talita,
pera aí. Opa,
eu travei, né? Acho tinha travado para
vocês. Aí
tinha travado. Desculpa. Eu acho que
tinha travado aqui. Travou, mas voltou,
né, gente? A que bom.
Obrigado. Obrigado.
Perfeito. Obrigado, gente.
Então aqui é porque para mim congelou a
tela. Desculpa.
Então aqui, olha só, quando a gente olha
pra Pâila, a gente cuida de cortisol e
insulina, gente, 15 kg em 45 dias. Ela
falou: "Renan: "Recuperei meu corpo de
25 anos quando ela veio contar a
história dela pra gente ao vivo.
E eu te digo, estão te tratando da forma
errada.
Não adianta você usar os pique, mjaro,
seutramina,
fazer bariátrica se isso não foi
tratado.
Eu quero te perguntar uma coisa.
Por tudo que você tá tendo aqui nessa
semana, você achou que a gente ia
entregar tanta coisa para você?
De verdade? Assim, pensa comigo, todo
material lindo, toda a plataforma, todas
as estratégias, você achou que você ia
ter tanta coisa assim pelo valor
simbólico que você investiu para estar
aqui?
Coloca aqui nos comentários que eu quero
saber. Você acha que tá pago o valor que
você investiu? Se você acha que tá pago,
coloca aqui nos comentários que eu quero
saber. Coloca aqui que eu quero saber.
Porque esse desafio nunca foi sobre só
jejum, ele é sobre você.
Ele é sobre você.
Para você se libertar desses traumas e
medos de tentar emagrecer, porque você
sempre acha que a culpa é sua
e não é. Você tá preso aqui, ó. Quem
quiser tirar print dessa tela, pode
tirar que isso aqui vai ter muito valor
pra maioria aqui, porque a maioria tá
presa nesse circuito. Se você tem uma
tireoide lenta, que que acontece com
quem tem tireoide lenta? Insulina altera
e cortisol cai. Por isso que eu digo, se
você tem a pontuação alterada na
tireoide, você tá presa no primeiro
circuito. Se você tem cortisol alto, sua
tireoide fica lenta. Glicose e insulina
sobe sem você precisar comer. E se você
tem resistência insulínica, seu fígado
fica pior. E o fígado ficou pior,
diminuiu a conversão dos hormônios da
tireoide e altera, aumenta cortisol.
Nada no nosso corpo é separado. Eu sou
totalmente contra esse loteamento da
medicina. totalmente contra esse
loteamento da medicina,
onde um cuida da cabeça, um cuida do
estômago, um cuida do intestino, um
cuida da tireide, um cuida daquilo, tá
tudo conectado.
Um órgão depende energeticamente do
outro e você não domina isso aqui. Agora
eu quero que vocês preparem print. Qual
a forma da gente começar a tratar isso,
hein, gente? Bem aqui. Qual a forma da
gente começar a tratar? cortisol
adaptógenos. Tem substâncias adaptógenas
naturais, uma delas, rodiola rosea, que
é um suplemento de 100 até 400 mg. Outro
magnésio, magnésio bisglicinato,
de 200 a 1000 mg.
e ele se toma à noite.
E se você dorme mal, a primeira coisa
que você precisa fazer para corrigir
cortisol é melhorar o sono. O magnésio
bisiglicinato ajuda no sono e além de
ajudar no cortisol, ele ajuda no sono. E
o chá faz um chá de mulungu com
camomila, uma colher de sopa de mulungu,
uma colher de sopa de camomila, chazinho
à noite. E se você é uma pessoa muito
estressada, estressa durante o dia, que
que você pode fazer? Técnica de
respiração. Técnica de respiração 365.
faz três vezes ao dia, seis respirações
por minuto. Como que é essa técnica de
respiração 365? Essa é uma técnica
cientificamente comprovada de respiração
que reduz o seu cortisol em 23%.
Gente, imagina uma técnica de respiração
que vai controlar cortisol. Você puxa o
ar em 3 segundos, rápido, enche o pulmão
em 3 segundos, segura seis, solta em
cinco. Faz isso seis vezes no dia. Aí
você tem que fazer umas três sequências
pelo menos.
Você relaxa na hora.
Passo para controlar sua tireoide. Tira
print. Quem aqui tem problema de
tireoide, tira print dessa tela aqui.
Vamos lá. Primeiro, quem tem o
hipotiroidismo tem que repol T3. Se você
não repou T3, não vai ter resultado, não
consegue manter emagrecimento. É muito
difícil emagrecer. Ah, mas o meu
endócrino falou que não precisa de T3. É
porque ele é desatualizado e muito
desatualizado.
Por quê? Deixa eu explicar isso aqui.
Por que que endócrino não repõe T3? Não
é o problema de endócrino. Eu fiz
endocrinologia. Eu sou médico, eu fiz
nutrologia, endocrinologia, prática
molecular, medicina integrativa,
nutrição esportiva, nutrição estética,
nutrição funcional, homeostase
endócrina, filosoziologia humana,
medicina chinesa.
E entenda uma coisa, T3 não é achismo.
Quem não sabe trabalhar com T3 é porque
está muito desatualizado. tem o livro de
endocrinologia que é o Williams
Textbook, que é o livro que a Sociedade
Brasileira de Endocrinologia usa na na
na nas residências de Endocrinologia,
Williams Textbook.
Só que nas últimas duas edições, ou
seja, há
há 8 anos, sai uma nova edição a cada 4,
5 anos.
Nas duas últimas edições, tá lá no
livro, se a pessoa utiliza remédio
tereoide e continua com sintomas de
tiroide, tem que reporter três. Está
escrito lá.
Só que um colega médico
endocrinologista,
ele mostrou o livro que ele que ele
tinha como base do estudo, que ele tava
terminando a residência,
tava utilizando a edição desse livro de
1999.
Já passaram quase 30 anos, gente.
Só que as últimas duas edições não tem
português, só em inglês. E custa caro,
custa quase R$ 4.000 um livro desse
e o pessoal não estuda. Então não é uma
questão de achismo, não dá para repor,
não pode repor. É uma questão de não
estudar. Ah, mas não tem comprovação
científica, tem lá centenas de evidência
científica.
Hoje eu já tenho mais de 20.000 1000
alunas que foram tratadas com reposição
de T3 e a vida muda. Você volta a sentir
viva,
só que precisa saber fazer reposição
correta. E o T3 se calcula.
O T3 se calcula. Sabe como eu preciso do
seu exame. Eu preciso do seu exame de
TSH e da dose seu reméreoide para fazer
o cálculo. Ele é individualizado, não
acha pronto para comprar, tem que ser
manipulado. Só que para regular tireoide
existem outras coisas muito importantes.
Você precisa tratar seu fígado, tem que
melhorar o sono. Amanhã a gente vai
falar tudo sobre sono, suplementos para
sono, técnicas para sono, tudo sobre
sono. Intestino também a gente vai falar
tudo amanhã.
e tem vitaminas essenciais paraa
conversão dos do T4 em T3. Então não
adianta só você tomar o remédioide, você
precisa de tirosina,
tirosina,
zinco bisiglicinato de 5 a 15 mg. Você
precisa de magnésio pra conversão. Você
precisa de selênio. Selênio dos
principais nutrientes. Selêniomeina
varia de 20 microg até 150 microg.
Então, três principais, se pudesse
utilizar selênio, zinco, tirosina, são
os principais cofatores de conversão. E
o iodo e o lugol, que muita gente
utiliza. Sim, o iodo é muito importante
pra função da tireoide, mas pra
conversão de T3 não é ele que vai fazer.
Ao invés de usar LOL, eu prefiro
Kelpodin. Aí varia de 20 microg microg,
dependendo do problema, entende?
Ah, Dr. Renan, mas como que eu vou
dormir bem se eu trabalho à noite? Você
vai dormir a hora que você chega em
casa. E aí você tem que enganar seu
cérebro. Você quando for dormir de dia,
você precisa comprar uma dose pitinha de
melatonina que você acha em qualquer
farmácia de 0,25 mg, quarto todo escuro,
tomou melatonina, seu cérebro acha que é
noite e aí você vive normal, tem uma
vida normal como qualquer pessoa.
Tira print, passo paraa resistência
insulínica. Primeiro, toda a alimentação
que a gente tá fazendo no desafio, ela
tem um princípio base de cuidado com
resistência insulínica. Ela tem esse
princípio base aqui. Então, controlar
farinha, açúcares, massas, pães,
biscoitos, bolachas, evitar pico de
glicose.
Se você colocar proteína em todas as
refeições, a velocidade de digestão do
dos alimentos vai diminuir. Então, sua
glicose não vai causar um pico de
glicose, proteína em todas as refeições.
Você não pode só pensar em controlar a
alimentação. Eu preciso entrar com
anti-inflamatórios naturais,
principalmente quem tem barriga, para
combater os radicais liberados pela
gordura visceral.
Jeju intermitente é fantástico pra
resistência que vocês estão fazendo. E
tem alguns componentes muito simples,
vinagre de maçã. Uma colher de sopa de
vinagre de maçã antes com um copo de
água, antes do almoço, antes do jantar,
diminuir em 50% o pico de glicosa e pico
de insulina. Então, um remédio
baratíssimo que vocês podem ter em casa,
diminuir 50% pico de glicosea, insulina.
E tem suplementos como a berberina.
Berberina funciona como uma metiformina
natural de manhã, de noite. Aí a dose
varia de 100 até 400 mg. E tem a
metiformina. Metiformina é um
medicamento utilizad utilizado por
diabéticos, mas não é um remédio de
diabetes. O diabético tem um benefício
com ela. A metiformermina trata
resistência à insulina. E alguma de
vocês com grau de resistência insulínica
elevado precisa de medicação e aí claro,
precisa de avaliação, de exames e tudo
mais. Uma insulina perfeita para quem
quer emagrecer nos exames tem que ser
abaixo de cinco em jejum. Uma insulina
perfeita.
Então aqui nós trabalhamos hoje essa
tríade cortisol, insulina, tireoide, a
nossa tríade hormonal. Em cima dessa
tríade hormonal, agora eu quero que você
identifique, será que eu tô presa nesse
circuito? Quem é que acha que tá presa
nesse circuito?
E à medida que a insulina baixa, manchas
escuras de axila, virilha, as
verruguinhas vão diminuindo.
Sim. Muita gente que tem melasma,
melasma ele piora por resistência
insulínica. À medida que você melhora a
resistência insulínica, melhora,
diminuir melasma. Diminui melasma.
E eu te pergunto, quem tá presa no
circuito?
Esse circuito?
E aí eu quero te perguntar de novo, você
acha que você tem culpa?
Não,
não tem culpa.
Nós falaremos sobre exames. Tudo sobre
exames, gente, na nossa aula de sábado.
Exames e suplementos para tudo. Tudo na
sua saúde que vão além da emagrecimento.
Suplementos e exames. A gente vai falar
tudo na aula de sábado, OK? Aula de
sábado.
Amanhã na nossa quarta aula.
Tem gente falou: "Estou acorrentada".
[risadas]
E é, mas é uma verdade. Você tá
amarrada. Não adianta você ter força de
vontade, não tem força de vontade que
vence isso. Amanhã na aula quatro vou
falar tudo sobre intestino, tratamento
de intestino, suplementos para
intestino, técnicas para intestino, tudo
sobre sono, suplementos para sono,
técnicas para sono. E vamos falar tudo
sobre todas as dietas para uma ciclagem
de dietas,
tudo.
E eu que eu quero te perguntar, você
percebe,
você percebe como a sua barriga ela é
mais resistente à perda de peso? Não é
por causa de dieta.
é hormonal, é metabólico. E esse mapa do
emagrecimento que vocês preencheram com
radar de problemas,
ele trouxe uma clareza que você nunca
teve nenhuma consulta médica que você
passou. E ele representa só 5%, escuta o
que eu tô falando, gente.
Ele representa só 5% de uma análise
completa.
Imagina da sua saúde, da base de
metabólica. Imagina
você tendo uma análise completa da sua
saúde.
E essa análise completa eu aplico em
cima de um rastreamento metabólico
individualizado que eu faço nas minhas
alunas.
Mas todo esse conhecimento que você tem,
saber que sua saúde tava ruim, você já
sabia, só não tava conseguindo enxergar.
Isso não era palpável para você ainda,
mas agora isso é palpável. E eu te
pergunto, quantas vezes vocês foram em
médicos, em nutres que só olham seus
exames, falam que tá tudo bem, te passam
dieta e remédio?
Como que você se sente vendo tudo que
você gastou de consulta, de médico, de
nutri, e você não teve
um diagnóstico como esse que você tá
tendo pelo valor simbólico que você
investiu para estar aqui?
Porque esse é nosso propósito, levar
conhecimento para vocês
novamente. Não conhecimento sobre dieta,
sobre jejum, conhecimento sobre você,
porque o que importa aqui é você.
Isso aqui não é sobre Dr. Renan, isso
aqui não é sobre jejum, é sobre você. E
eu te falei isso desde a primeira aula.
E para você ter ainda mais conhecimento
sobre você e tratamento sobre você, que
eu libero agora a nossa terceira chave
secreta. Lembrando que cada uma das
aulas eu libero um cadeadinho que são
presentaços aqui para vocês.
E a nossa terceira chave secreta é um
e-book completo de base hormonal
metabólica. Um ebook completo de base
hormonal metabólica. Eu vejo vocês aqui,
ó, me sinto fracassada olhando para
trás, né? Me sinto mal com tudo isso.
E esse ebook completo de base hormonal
metabólica, você vai ter tudo que a
gente falou aqui e mais um pouco todos
os materiais. Não posso ficar mostrando
aqui para vocês.
Entendido?
E temos o nosso terceiro bônus dessa
nossa terceira aula. Esse aqui é só para
quem tá ao vivo. E aqui, meninas, o que
que é esse nosso terceiro bônus?
Farmácia da barriga. O que que é essa
farmácia da barriga? Opa, deixa eu
colocar aqui assim. O que que é a nossa
farmácia da barriga? São alguns
suplementos que ajudam na barriga. E
aqui algumas explicações. E como que
você pega a nossa farmácia da barriga,
todo o material com a explicação desse
suplementação,
você tem que preencher a nossa lista de
presença. Daqui a pouco eu vou colocar
aqui o link da nossa lista de presença.
Lá no final da lista de presença, você
vai ter o link para você poder baixar a
nossa o nosso bônus dessa terceira aula.
É um bônus melhor do que o outro. E a
soma desses bônus fazem parte desse
protocolo acelera metabolismo.
Preencha a lista de presença no final da
aula e assim você consegue baixar a
nossa lista. Então, quero combinar uma
coisa aqui com vocês. Nós temos os
nossos posts que eu faço lá no Instagram
e a gente tá de olho em quem comenta,
porque em quem comenta, isso conta
pontos pra gente escolher a nossa campeã
do concurso. Então, vamos lá. Opa.
Então aqui, ó, eu vou postar essa foto
aqui, essa foto aqui
no meu perfil do Instagram e eu quero
que você vá lá e escreva #uomenoculpa
nesse post do Instagram.
Isso faz parte,
primeiro que tudo que você escreve se
manifesta na sua vida de forma mais
rápido, mas principalmente você consegue
mudar a forma como você pensa sobre
você. Quando você vai lá e escreve #u
não tenho culpa, isso quer dizer que
você entendeu que provavelmente você tá
acorrentado em um circuito que te
domina, que você não tem controle. Você
não tem controle sobre seus hormônios.
Você não escolheu ter problema de
tireoide. Quem quem é que escolheu ter
problema de tireoide?
Quem é que escolheu ter problema
tireoide? Você não escolheu ter problema
tireide? Você não escolheu ter problema
de cortisol? Você não escolheu ter
metabolismo lento?
Então você vai lá nesse post e vai
colocar #uão tenho culpa e você vai me
me contar o que que você descobriu sobre
você, do por que você não tem culpa.
E assim a gente não só faz esse trabalho
de mentalidade dia após dia, mas você
assume um compromisso com você. Um
compromisso de se dar valor, de se amar,
de se perdoar. É quando a gente falar se
perdoe, às vezes sou sou
e conversa de coach, sabe? Mas não é, é
porque isso é uma realidade. Você até
aqui achava que a culpa era você porque
você não tinha força de vontade. Mas não
é força de vontade. Porque lembra que eu
te mostrei que a sua mochila tá muito
carregada, carregada de
responsabilidades que não são suas. Ou
você acha que são suas porque você acha
que você é útil quando você tá servindo
o outro. Mas e você? Por que que você
não serve mais a você do que você serve
ao outro? Porque você se sente culpada.
E quando a pessoa se sente culpada, ela
precisa mostrar serviço pro outro, ela
precisa fazer mais pro outro para se
sentir amada.
Então hoje vocês vão colocar #u
tenho culpa #u não tenho culpa no nosso
post do Instagram, porque isso conta
pontos na hora da gente escolher a
campeã do concurso. Porque essa semana,
gente, nós temos sorteio e temos
concurso nessa semana. sorteio. A gente
já vai colocar o link da chamada de
presença aqui, viu? E o que que é o
sorteio que tá rolando essa semana? O
sorteio é o seguinte: quem preencher
todas as listas de presença, todas as
listas de presença, na nossa sétima
aula, que é domingo, ao vivo, eu vou
fazer o sorteio do meu kit de
suplementos. Esse kit de suplementos não
tá vendo. Eu não vendo isso. Eu não
vendo suplementos. Essas fórmulas são
criadas e desenvolvidas por mim.
Primeiro, a pílula do pãozinho, que é
uma fórmula que você toma antes de uma
refeição livre. E ela atrapalha a
absorção de uma refeição livre.
E você pode tomar, comer a sua pizza do
final de semana com sua família sem
culpa. o gelzinho dos sonhos, que ajuda
na libido feminina, que as alunas amam
isso aqui, e o fitoterápico para energia
e disposição. E ajuda também na libido
de tabela, mas mais energia e
disposição. Esse é o foco dele. Então,
ao vivo, quem preencher todas as listas
de presença, ah, Renan, mas eu não
preenchi, ó, lá no no link da aula, abre
a descrição da aula, você consegue
preencher se deu algum erro, se deu
algum problema, ok? E temos o concurso
que tá rolando. O que que é o concurso?
O concurso você tem que ter tirado sua
foto de antes e depois lá no começo da
semana. Ainda dá tempo, né? E no final
da semana, lá no sábado, vou liberar uma
tarefa onde você vai contar tudo que
aconteceu, principalmente as
transformações. E a campeã do concurso
que a gente vai escolher, ela vai vir
representando todos vocês. Ela vai
ganhar a análise do mapa do
emagrecimento dela, ela vai ganhar esse
kit de suplementos
e ela ganha uma vaga garantida no PEF
360, que é meu programa de emagrecimento
feminino mais completo com meu
acompanhamento, com acompanhamento do
meu time para você ter o seu
rastreamento metabólico, a seu
devolutivo, seu tratamento, análise de
exames, análise de sua saúde para você
emagrecer todos aquilos que você quiser.
É meu programa de acompanhamento mais
completo. Então, recomendo que vocês
sejam engajadas, participativas, estejam
aqui com a gente e vão lá no post e
coloca a nossa hashtag eu não tenho
culpa porque cada comentário lá do post
de vocês, depois a gente consegue mapear
isso, conta pontinhos, não é claro o o
obrigatório, mas conta pontinhos, porque
isso faz parte da construção dessa
mentalidade forte que eu quero que você
tenha sobre você, dessa nova nova visão
que você tenha sobre você. Entendido,
meninas? E amanhã a nossa quarta aula tá
ainda mais surreal, porque eu vou falar
sobre sono, intestino e sobre ciclagem
de dietas, sobre todas as dietas, o
benefício de cada dieta, como isso
acelera seu metabolismo, seu
emagrecimento, tá surreal? E temos,
claro, o quarto bônus para quem tiver ao
vivo. O a lista de presença está no
chat. Meninas, mais uma vez muito
obrigado. Eu quero agradecer o carinho
de todos vocês. E o bônus você acha a
hora que você preenche a lista de
presença, só para quem tá ao vivo, tá?
Se não tá ao vivo, não consegue. Link de
lista de presença, vai lá assina a lista
de presença e no final vai ter um botão
para você poder baixar o nosso bônus.
Meninas, um beijo, vejo vocês amanhã que
tá ainda mais surreal a aula. Deu muito,
muito, muito obrigado. Vejo vocês.
Mais ou menos do anos eu venho em efeito
platô. Olá, meu nome é Jana, tenho 39
anos.
>> A minha barriga é muito grande, isso me
incomoda bastante. Cabelo ralinho,
caindo, unhas quebrando, tudo. Nunca
posso ter uma unha grande e pele muito
ressecada. nos braços, pernas,
calcanhares ficam rachados, né, pelo
ressecamento. Então, eu tive que tirar o
útero ovário. Com isso, eu entrei numa
menopausa antes do tempo, comecei a
engordar, [música]
mas fora isso, a qualidade da minha
saúde também junto. Então, meus exames
todos desregulados, tiroide desregulada,
[música]
sono desregulado,
tudo. E com com o desafio dos s dias, eu
percebi que estava pior do que eu
imaginava. E o mais triste é ir médicos
e eles me falarem: "Como você não pode
tomar hormônios, a gente não tem nada
para fazer por você. Você tem que ser
grata, porque você está viva, você tá
aqui com a sua família e com o seu
filho." Então assim, eu fui sentenciada
a viver do jeito que eu estava vivendo.
Comecei a engordar depois da minha
gravidez há 25 anos atrás. [música] E o
meu os meus o meu peso ideal ideal ideal
seria 65 kg e eu cheguei esse mês a 90
kg.
>> [música]
>> Sempre tive aquela de sanfona que falam,
né, que emagrece, engorda, emagrece,
engorda. Eu não queria nem, ah, cheguei
ao ponto de pensar, a partir de agora eu
vou engordar 120 kg para poder fazer
bariátrica para voltar pro meu peso,
porque para mim era tinha que ser tudo
cirurgia, medicação. Comecei acreditando
que iria conseguir.
>> Eu estou [música] na obesidade nível
dois. Nós não acreditamos mais em nós.
No meu caso, era assim. tantas
tentativas, tantas dietas, eh atividade
física e sem o controle da alimentação,
sem conhecer o que eu posso e o que eu
não posso comer e quais são os melhores
horários para isso. Eh, descobrir o que
é que tá atrapalhando o meu sono e
dentre outros sintomas. Bom dia.
[música] Meu nome é Adriana. Eu venho de
um processo de uma cirurgia que eu
engordei bastante [música]
e há muito tô sentindo unha fraca,
cabelo caindo, ficando bem careca, bem
um cabelo bem falhado [música] e achando
normal, menopausa,
idade, assim normal. Aí percebi que a
minha tireoide [música]
estava me trazendo para esse lugar que
não me pertence, [música] não me
pertence mesmo. Eu já tenho 60 anos e
quero aposentar, [música] viajar,
aproveitar a vida. Não quero ser uma
velha de 60 anos, gorda, com dores e sem
anos saí. Fiquei extremamente feliz e
empolgada quando me pesei hoje pela
manhã, porque eu perdi 4,5,
>> diminuí 4 kg, [música] a minha barriga
tá bem menor. Tem sido muito prazeroso
ver a minha barriga desinchar, né? Eu
diminuí muito a barriga nesses dias de
jejum.
>> Em menos de 7 dias, eu eliminei 4 kg
e estou muito feliz, muito feliz. deu
assim uma redução nas medidas e as
roupas, né, estão a gente percebe nas
roupas e eu já estou muito feliz. Eu
alcancei a meta de 3,1.
Estou muito feliz. Já perdi 3 kg. Muito
feliz com os resultados que [música] eu
que eu já alcancei até agora e pretendo
alcançar mais, mais e mais, porque eu
quero me manter com corpo bacana. com
corpo saudável, principalmente pela
minha saúde, não tanto por emagrecer,
mas pela minha saúde. Muito feliz, bem
mais magra, bem [música] mais sem
barriga.
Olha a minha [música] feliz demais,
muito feliz com esse resultado. Eu
agradeço imensamente a você, Dr. Renan,
doqui, pelo apoio. Perdi 4, 400 g. Eu
não achava assim que eu me senti que eu
estava mais leve. Isso foi muito bom.
>> Hoje fazem seis dias que eu estou na
dieta. Eu consegui perder 4,700 g. Eu
foram eliminados 6,g, mas vai muito além
do peso.